how about we start with you guys
explaining what you do and then we'll go
back in time and talk about like how you
ended up doing YC and all the rest of it
also sure so we're nonprofit one of the
first ones to go through Y Combinator
and we build houses and communities
throughout the developing world so right
now throughout Haiti and Latin America
and you can kind of envision a a plot of
land and then about 200 to 300 homes
being designed like kind of like an
urban designer would do for some of the
poorest people in the world is the
really high level of that and Ali can
add onto that yeah so we'll essentially
work with local governments will get
large pieces of land typically granted
bring in utilities subdivide the land
and then families who are previously
living in let's say 10 slums in Haiti
post earthquake or inactive landslide
zones that El Salvador will bring those
families into the communities they
actually helped design the homes and the
communities and then the families not
only own the houses but they own the
land that the home sits on and land
ownership is so crucial as a path out of
poverty mm-hmm and were you guys working
on nonprofits before or did you just get
excited about this idea yeah it was I
definitely was not yeah probably last
thing in the world I thought I'd be
doing and like literally but I I kind of
had a big 180 in my life
and then when I was in my early 20s I
had a for-profit startup before this so
loved entrepreneurship love technology
love innovation all the things then took
a trip to Haiti a couple years after the
2010 earthquake
so like not right after but there's like
a couple years after but it looked like
it was a few months after you know and
and which is blown away by the tens of
thousands of people that we're living in
tents because the earthquake destroyed
like how close like a million households
yeah like that and everybody was given
temporary aid right which is necessary
at the time but it was once this lasts
for like maybe 90 days and as of today
it's been almost I mean over eight years
and people are still living in tents
like little kit
and her you know three little girls are
living in a tent with no protection from
intruders from storms from anything and
you kind of just go back to like first
principles Maslow's hierarchy and think
food water and I think sometimes we
forget about shelter and you just we saw
it firsthand and came back and right
before I met Alexandria I actually try
to find other nonprofits that could like
really champion and support and then
we're solving this issue and then as we
went out started telling more people
about it kind of found another problem
which was skepticism and so many people
that were skeptical about where their
money actually went mmm
right so we're here in Silicon Valley
were giving to X organization how is the
money actually being spent it kind of
seems like a black hole what person is
going how efficient is it like all these
things and so we uncovered another
problem which was a lack of transparency
a lack of accountability and kind of
like a status quo yeah in a sense and
then teamed up with Alexandria or other
co-founder Matthew and like the early
catalyst was how do we take those pain
points that we know donors have right
like our end user reverse engineer a new
experience for that and then we also
have another obviously the most
important end user which is the families
that we partner with and how do we
provide a better experience for them as
well which ally can talk through and now
is how it started but just to clarify
there were companies or nonprofits
working in this space the money which is
kind of like you know seeps out from
little cracks in the business and then
and kind of end up living in tents yeah
at this point three years into doing
this work we've kind of come across and
research and talked to over a hundred
right well over a hundred different
organizations focused on housing yeah an
unfortunate well the good news start
with the good news the good news is that
there are a lot of you know people and
organizations that care about this right
so there's a lot of money being put
towards social housing yeah the bad news
is there's a huge spectrum with respect
to what Brett mentioned like the donor
experience transparency accountability
what's actually happening with
funds that are being allocated there but
then also unfortunately on the quality
side so the spectrum of quality of
output of the homes and the communities
that are being built it's it's dark you
have some good quality stuff but a lot
of it leans towards you know fairly
subpar which is part of the problem
we're trying to solve yeah so like one
example and I won't name the
organization but it was a pretty
prominent article this is actually like
right before we went through Y
Combinator it was one of the largest
humanitarian organizations like a bunch
of big headlines came out that they
raised basically like half a billion
dollars and within like six years had
only built and this is not an
exaggeration I think like six houses mhm
it's like [ __ ] not an exaggerated super
nice I don't think moving the Haiti's so
I didn't get to mention I won't go too
much into but my background is almost
entirely in international development
work right that's what I became
passionate about when I was fifteen like
kind of solving poverty is like my
life's mission or putting it you know
dent in extreme poverty that's what I
studied did a lot of work with you know
various organizations in Latin America
and Africa etc and you know became
fairly jaded and I worked I think a lot
of people in the space you know become
and then doing international development
work and having a decent understanding
of that led me to want to understand
poverty more deeply here in the United
States and so I did Teach for America
and unfortunately about a third of my
students were homeless for either all or
part of the year and through the lens of
those students I got to see that when
you have housing instability your
attendance in school decreases that
leads to performance decreasing mental
and physical health impacts parents
ability to attain and retain jobs and so
when Brett and I had our first
conversation about you know building
homes in Haiti and solving that issue I
was just really excited about the
opportunity to see what the broad
ranging you know implications of that
could be so that's how you know I got
super passionate about how
as it relates to poverty and then
through my experience in development
work you know Brett mentioned that large
organization only building six homes you
know that organization didn't build six
homes and then pocket the rest of the
money right what really happened if you
look you know deeper into it is you know
they said that they were gonna build
however many thousand homes they
realized things like getting land is
extremely difficult things like doing
quality control on homes
post-disaster is incredibly difficult
and so they shifted away from that need
and you know focused on things that were
important a little easier to do etc and
so I think that you know highlights one
of the core reasons why we've been
successful is because we value truly
partner with you know heavily vet local
partners the one of the biggest
observations in my work internationally
is that everywhere you go you spin the
globe point your finger everywhere you
go there are competent people and
organizations who are going to know
their communities how to do business in
those locations better than you ever
will and it'll be very presumptuous of
us as you know very at that point where
24 years old right people with ambition
to say like we're gonna go into Haiti
we're gonna go into all solid or and
make a difference what we did which I
think you know is crucial to our success
is find locals who help us to navigate
effectively they're uniquely positioned
to help us be successful yeah so what
does it look like in the very beginning
so you meet and you're like okay we're
gonna work on housing specifically in
Haiti at this point yeah does that mean
like you take a trip and try and find
contractors and build one on your own do
you raise money first what do you do
yeah I think it and kind of going back
to so we had already like before we got
into YC yeah we were already like loving
like homemade or like listening to
podcasts like all the big point of
connection between us right I think you
were surprised like oh this person who's
like a non-profit background watches or
ships cool yeah
unfortunately uniqueness and and if you
kind of go to I mean like really a core
value we all have is make something
people want
mm-hm and we looked at that from really
to two users right so the first was a
large pool of donors that I mean
everybody listening right now like if we
said hey give a thousand dollars to an
international large organization how
many of you would actually trust where
100% of the money goes how efficient it
is the end results and right and the
reality is about half the people would
say no hmm right and so how do we how do
we make something that they want right
and then we designed our experience we
can get into later right that got
traction and then to always point
earlier how do we make something that
our end users want where we know they
don't want just you know lark but they
don't want us going down there and
building homes for them and like these
super large organizations without using
local talent and local materials and
local jobs and so that was really the
catalyst yeah if how things got started
and then so we had the idea and then now
getting into MVP mode mm-hmm we were
super young we were 24 we had you know
really no capital of our own and so we
had the idea of the donors I was really
three steps the first one was we were to
make our own crowdfunding site so you
could see the family right kind of like
Kickstarter you could see a picture of
the family read their story and you can
give directly to them second thing is
that 100% of what you give will go
towards building the house what's not
going to cover any of our overhead and
we do that by having a couple private
donors that fund all of our overhead yet
like private investors basically and in
the third part was when the family moved
in we wanted to be extremely accountable
to the donors and so and was also one of
the best days of the family's lives
right think about it they've been living
in I mean like hell on earth conditions
legit for seven years and they get into
a new house it's one of the best days of
their lives and so we take a simple
moving video and we send that back to
all the donors right so that simple user
experience of see the family upfront
digitally one hundred percent goes to it
and then you get to see the end result
of the video that was the initial
contest
and in the way that we wanted to launch
it was we didn't have an engineer at the
time actually and we didn't have any
money so so we may I'm gonna give a plug
to uh to web flow is web fluid yeah yeah
so um other co-founder Matthew his
nickname is MacGyver just because he can
like legit do anything we said alright
we're gonna make basically a fake
crowdfunding platform on web flow and so
we staged it as basically looking like
our own crowdfunding platform that we
built organically we're donors could
come online and see the family have the
crowdfunding meter have the percentage
all the things give directly to it and
when that happened our MVP was Matthew
Alexandrian ourselves we would just
update the landing page and literally
like go in and move them yeah so it's
all like static yeah but it would be
like I'm at a dinner can you like we
just got donation can you go in and you
go in you do a quick calculation this is
the percentage and you like move the
meter over they were a few mistakes yeah
it was always like you know usually a
delay and people would call or email and
say did it go and our good excuse was
credit card processing like it takes a
little bit of time you know and then we
we still hadn't and then we were like
okay well we're gonna still prove them
he and will when the homes are built
will just like good in ourselves and do
the videos yeah and so we actually I
think it's a good startup lesson we were
able to launch that concept like legit
and only a few weeks and and we started
getting money and we got a decent amount
of money we got like a hundred thousand
dollars within like like a couple months
and that allowed us to use a local
partner that we had already known in
Haiti that had a long a lot of
experience there build our first six
houses we went down to not build the
homes because we employ local workers to
take the videos see the impact and then
we send it back to everybody and that
happened in a very short period of time
and then we applied to I see after that
I think that you know just really
emphasizes core principles right like
something people want like we wouldn't
have gotten that traction gotten over
$100,000 in the matter of a couple of
weeks if it wasn't an experience that
people really liked people were shocked
at the beginning like you're gonna send
me a video of like this exact family I
just met on the website moving into
their house you know if that about you
that's something that you know I want to
be a part of yes we would get we would
say yeah this is cool I want to be a
part of it
but also this is not going to scale well
of course you know it so I guess that's
the other lesson too right do you think
that don't scale I mean for those first
few months like we were literally just
pulling in our computers and updating
the website constantly did you have a
design house jobs yeah let's just say
that we have jobs so it would be like in
the middle of like the work day of my
like supply chain logistics dog running
to my computer like moving a meter so
you just like you don't make it happen
yeah we partnered with an organization
that had already started a project and
so like we didn't have to start
everything from scratch
okay I just felt like okay validate and
DP validate this is something people
want yeah and prove it with them and
then after that we go okay and where you
set up as a non-profit at the time or
you just ran the money through yeah oh
you saw Wow
know what yeah not immediately it just
takes some time it's actually a process
that takes probably much longer than a
couple weeks yeah a couple of months I
know that's why I was surprised when you
were saying like we got it all done a
couple weeks I was like hmm yeah yeah so
people knew in the beginning like you
know we're not a non-profit yet they're
making the donation knowing that yeah
and then you know we were able to give
tax deductions kind of in retro was it
retrospective gotcha yeah yeah through
our partner yeah yeah cool okay and so I
see yeah yeah and what changed about the
business when you got into I see and
went through thinking bigger I think was
one of the key ones so Kevin Hale Aaron
Harris cap money Alec they were our
partners one of them yes and I remember
I was at my apartment building we had
our fur you know you get in and you have
your first kind of call with your
partner to set your goal for the
three-month stint that is why see right
what's either like your revenue goal
your customer goal whatever for us it
was how many home
we were going to fund and by the way our
homes are about six thousand dollars but
yeah okay context yeah so Kevin asked us
you know what what are your goals for
home funding and we said you know this
year this was 2015 in the year of 2015
we want to do a hundred homes and he
said okay great you're gonna do a
hundred homes during YC so we're gonna
take your 12-month goal and make it a
3-month goal right so then we launched
this a hundred homes in a hundred days
and I think a funny story is that we
agreed to it right cuz you know where
NYC like we can't say no and we hang up
the phone and I was actually like guys I
think we should call them back like we
just set a goal that we cannot
accomplish like this is not smart yada
yada yada so I was being a lot more
conservative and we were just like we
just got to figure out how to do it
yeah and so one of our big core team
values now is you know think big break
down and execute so you have this big
goal you just have to you know this is
not news but like backwards plan it and
we did that and then actually hit a
hundred homes in like 92 days so we are
yeah so during YC was just tons of
fundraising basically to get these
things going yeah Fogg bought a fund
raising a lot of outreach and and
getting people excited about our model
and why it's different and then and like
most importantly the direct
life-changing impact that somebody can
make for a pretty achievable amount of
money about $6,000 mm-hm
and and that back to what we learned I
think it really just infused in our DNA
setting very audacious goals and then
saying like okay no BS like what would
it take if we had to hit this right and
then reverse engineering back to there
and then you know making your weekly
plan in executing and that has that was
the beginning and then there's been a
lot of other stages where we've apply of
course that same principle so an
anecdote that I'll give is you know YC
ended the summer of 2015 we had our
annual planning meeting for 2016 that
ended that year and we said you know how
many homes are we gonna fund do we do
200 and I figured who said it but it was
like what would it take to do 800 homes
like but you know just let's just
a huge number that's even conceivable
because that hundred homes in 100 days
seemed inconceivable and we did it
so we threw a huge number out there and
just said let's just brainstorm if we
had to do what would we do and you know
long story short that launched the
architects program which exists now at a
news story where companies actually fund
entire communities right instead of
doing you know one-off homes we said if
we're gonna hit a big number we need
people to be doing bulk right maybe
people to be doing you know big swaths
of homes and that was gonna catch it and
successful and when we said that at the
beginning of 2016
within three months we had what two or
three companies that had agreed to do
communities so it was really a shift in
our thinking of what's possible and you
have to challenge yourself in order to
see you know what you can achieve and
then and then taking the right steps to
package that idea and then go test it
yeah right so like not saying all right
we're gonna shift all our strategy and
like everything's gonna focus on this
it's like you know fire up for a bullet
before cannon ball kind of doing right
so you create a package and you
shouldn't send off the companies and you
see what resonates and then all of a
sudden it's like oh we have this program
iterate right it's like and that when
the program is like you know because our
homes are so low-cost they're not six
thousand dollars per home a hundred home
community where they'd be like all
together like designed beautifully and
intelligently with the families that's
about six hundred thousand dollars right
which is not cheap but it's pretty
achievable for a large company so that's
how we that's how easy yeah and it's
very high impact seem intuitively and
something else that seemed pretty
unachievable
last year or pretty audacious like just
thinking of this mindset is you know
with building a 3d printer but yes super
young team fairly early organization
doing something that's very much a
technological challenge and in some of
the hardest places in the world to work
so yeah before we get there one thing I
am curious about is so you're dealing
with all this apprehension around where
does the money go right
and so
one example of how you guys are dealing
with that is just showing the output
right but are people asking for other
things like you talk about how your
model is like better than others in the
sense that you're maybe more transparent
more efficient but in in like very clear
practical terms what does that mean so
other people can follow so actually our
first hire after Y C which we had a lot
of funding growth was okay impact right
and so we didn't go out and hire more
marketing we didn't go out and hire more
so we actually heard impact data manager
Ali can talk about shout out Emma she's
amazing and we that was our first thing
was we wanted to set up this like very
rigorous impact data program which Ali
can talk through yeah cuz it's not
actually number of homes is a vanity
metrics right yeah what if those homes
are empty what if those homes aren't
actually better than what people were in
before what if those homes are crumbling
right yeah so the impact like what is
the change in people's lives once they
move into the home is actually what
matters and so to Brett's point we've
invested a lot into really understanding
what that impact is things like you know
when families move into a home there
they increase their amount of sleep by
like three to five hours you see
immediate healthy Delta by the way yeah
we're hours to like almost eight hours
yeah I'm saying and you can extrapolate
right like what the impact you know the
broad I mean that was a life-changing
thing for me in the past few years
realizing just how much it like for
recovery it's the number one for it I'm
at people that have kids listening like
like seriously imagine if your kid was
only getting four hours of sleep yeah
like every night life is a nightmare and
having to like like when it rains at
night well usually mud or rain or sewage
will go through the floor yeah right and
you don't have enough beds and you're
half in your tent for everybody so that
means the kids are sleeping on the floor
so that means when it's bad weather oh
that stinks you have to stand up the
whole night and then good try to go to
school the next day right and then do it
again
like it's just a little basic human good
stuff that
is so life-changing that we believe
shelter can provide absolutely you know
we're also not just building homes right
we're building entire communities right
so these are these kind of like micro
economies you see entrepreneurship that
pops up in the communities you know we
do a lot in the beginning with community
planning to plan for feelings of safety
and community cohesion like how homes
are place where we have greens maybe
people want exactly same principle and
so the other big thing on the data is
yes obviously we want to know what's
working
but like the most important thing about
our data program and we act cannot
encourage other organizations do the
same thing is we do it to figure out how
do we make decisions from this right how
do I make the it influence decisions of
like okay what's not working right and
then we can try it we can iterate and we
can test and we can do a lot of new a be
testing that we're doing now the same
type of principles that good startups
have right like we believe there should
be no difference and how a nonprofit
operates you collect data to make your
business better not just like show the
data on the site not just her
fundraising unfortunately a lot of
nonprofits you know they start
collecting data because they have to
because they're not going to get money
if they ask you for this exactly and it
should be used to influence the
organization so like our goal is for
every community to be better than the
previous one based on the data that
we've collected hmm and how do you
communicate that on the site because
that you you still have to deal with the
psychology of these people like I'm
wanting to donate totally um how do we
communicate the data on the same yeah
we're still we're still working on
visualizations at this point and like
it's just so kind of early into it yeah
yeah so again we were three years old
yeah and so we did a lot the way that we
do it is we collect baseline data so you
know what are people's living conditions
before and then work you know families
move into a home and then you do six
months twelve months two years and so
we're really at the point now it's an
exciting point in the organization where
we're starting to get some really
bus data on what the impact of a home is
and you know transparently we're really
thinking about what are the best ways to
a communicate that and then more
importantly to use that information to
change what we're doing on the ground to
be better practitioners so what made you
want to do the 3d printing well so is it
a data partners now if we go back to
kind of in the beginning days was how do
you do 100 homes yeah and then they do a
thousand homes then it's like wow
there's about a billion people in the
world right which is like more
overwhelming that do not have correct
one of like a basic sorry I do not have
one of life's most basic human needs
shelter right and so we thought okay
well we obviously can't solve that
ourselves as one organization yeah but
how can we start to think through new
innovations and new R&D that if it works
we could be able to prove it in our
communities that we could do it
exponentially faster better and a higher
quality mmhmm right so there's kind of
thing that I like it's too good to be
true right but if it works it's we
believe it could be a breakthrough and
then we want to prove that in our
communities and then not keep that from
new story right like no this is our IP
like sorry guys like we've got this 3d
printer but then open source or
democratized that so with all the other
nonprofits and governments around the
world really the social whole social
housing sector and so we can talk more
about that methodology later but
Alexandria started looking into a lot of
other a lot of different things right
for innovation and how do we how do we
create exponentially faster better and
higher quality
mm-hm and 3d home printing came up and
to the top and then you can talk a
little bit more on that
yeah and for context the the houses you
were previously making or still are
making how are they made with CMU block
so it's in a very traditional
construction method they're cement
blocks it's reinforced with steel rebar
it's incredibly safe for seismic
conditions or hurricane prone conditions
so we are completely satisfied with the
way that we build houses now as far as
durability resilience
etc the big question was how do we build
homes like Brett said faster less
expensively without compromising quality
because that's the only way we're gonna
you know hit that big number or even you
know try to scratch the surface of that
big number of housing inequality yeah so
we started just doing some research the
beginning of beginning of last year
there were a few things
promising construction innovations that
rose to the surface we also found out
that there's just not been a lot of
advances in construction over the past
few decades right it's such an archaic
space that there's isn't a lot of there
isn't a lot of momentum and change since
the 1950s like things haven't really
been passable wearing it right for the
interruption was not a lot of incentives
by the big players to invest in R&D and
invest in changing the way that things
are are done and so you know long story
short 3d printing was one of the things
that rose to the top and the technology
is there the technology you know last
year when we were looking into it was
there to be printing homes we should
describe this in a little more detail
because especially if the people are
listening and can't watch a video yeah
it's not 3d printing in the sense that
you've seen before with a filament it's
a different material entirely and in a
much larger scale but what yeah what
material are using yeah so I I love that
question because typically when I when
someone hasn't seen the video yeah yeah
and maybe we can link to the video yeah
3d printing you'll see the video yeah 3d
homework so when you when I say it to
people they're like is this home made
out of plastic or like they're they're
thinking about like the desktop printers
and what that prints out it look how
does that build a home it's printed with
with the most common most readily
available material in construction that
exists it's built with what cement right
so if you think about a hose that you
know that with water right like a water
hose you have in your backyard think of
cement coming out
zedd and then you use that cement and
you you know print the perimeter and the
interior walls of the home and then you
go and you print another layer on top of
that so layer by layer you are creating
a you know complete thermal envelope
you're creating an incredibly durable
structure think about the cement locks
that I mentioned right
you know that's many hundreds or
thousands of parts that are put together
at each point there's opportunity to
make a mistake right versus a technology
where it's one continuous loop of this
very strong material so we're confident
that not only are these homes going to
be as good as traditional methods but
there's a huge opportunity and we're
already seeing signs through testing
that it's going to actually be much
stronger yeah mmm and you know ways like
Brett mentioned it's a nearly zero waste
construction method which also helps
reduce cost yeah
and how he went about this was once we
figured out we wanted to try it first of
all we met an amazing partner that we
work with very public they called icon
the robotic construction startup company
and this was not like there was no 3d
home printer machine out there that we
could like buy parts of like we had to
make it it was no manual yeah and so
like we literally as a non-profit we
unfortunately have somewhat of a license
to do this because we have a private set
of donors that believe in R&D and
calculated risk and innovation and so we
actually had the funding to to fund the
R&D efforts of this right so we had to
make the 3d home printing machine which
is I think the largest machine in the
country right now I'm pretty sure 3d
home printer and then we'd to print the
first house right and we did that two
weeks ago in Austin Texas and it turned
out I mean the reality is it turned out
probably better than we anticipated it
looks great and it passed the Austin
City housing code which is actually
really strict code and when we tested
the PSI levels actually came in three
times stronger than our normal
cinderblock homes so what
PSI levels like compression strength
yeah oh yeah so that was our proof of
concept hmm and and then the promise of
3d home printing when we look at really
three bullets one is cost right so right
now our homes on average are about
$6,500 per home we believe with 3d home
printing we can get that down to about
$3,000 over time not in the beginning
but overtime and then speed so right now
take about 15 days about a house this
would be under 24 hours and then under
12 hours is the goal Wow yeah and then
you have to do that without sacrificing
quality of course and we believe we can
actually increase quality and make it
stronger more durable zero waste etc so
when you when you talk about these
numbers like 6500 now 3,000 later yeah
is that all in that includes labor
everything per unit yeah okay and so I
saw that the house in Austin is that
like the the basically the model for the
future homes or are they like do they
have the same fixtures and windows and
all that stuff is that a yeah yeah the
the roof will be a bit different so in
each in each place that we work our
homes are a bit different right you have
to develop them for local contacts and
communities actually are like I
mentioned earlier very involved in the
process of Community Design so we don't
just copy-paste you know different types
of homes so the homes will look
different the size the size will be
about the same and the home in Austin
but some fixtures based on you know what
windows we can get locally we want to
support local manufacturers in Haiti for
example people do not want to live under
roofs that they feel are very heavy
because so many people died in the
earthquake with the roofs caving in
right so we intentionally use some very
lightweight roofing materials and that
would probably be different in Haiti but
this the size will be you know pretty
much the same the size and then the
construction methodology will be
essentially the same how does the
plumbing work and electrical yeah so
this is a bit hard to explain without
seeing the video but the the printer is
printing kind of like let's think of it
as like two
ooh - like a interior and exterior aha
printed layers of cement and then inside
there's kind of little triangles so
that's spacing that you can you know
wire and that you can put plumbing
through mm-hmm and then the printer
actually is you know it's pretty smart
you you know upload a CAD file and it
knows where to stop and start so if you
think about where the window is sits we
don't have to like you know carve into
the right the structure like the printer
knows to stop at a certain point and to
start at a certain point it can do the
same thing for areas where fixtures need
to kind of feed through into the home
yeah and that point is actually really
exciting to us because if you just
imagine for our use case which is the
families that we work with in some of
the poorest places in the world we would
actually be able to offer them different
type of templates and even help
customize the homes right because of the
the technology which right now we just
can't do yeah and you have more design
freedom in how you can design stuff so
it doesn't have to be like a rectangle
or a square you could actually make it
circular which is how the first one was
done as well which is extremely exciting
from an architectural standpoint
aesthetic and but also like you know how
we can use it it's not any more
expensive or difficult to design and
like loops and curves as it is to do
straight lines right how do you get a
curved window but yeah yeah and kind of
the design thing is important because
when you look at social housing
developments now yeah whether you have
two kids or eight kids typically you're
in the same house right and if you have
a disability I mean tough luck right so
you know we can design houses that again
kind of best meet the needs of
individual families which happens for
you and I right and we don't think it
should be any different for people just
because they don't have as much you know
purchasing power because of where they
were born yeah yeah yes sir I would just
I'm not trying to plug in your story but
see the video like visually like it's
really amazing I'm worth and I yeah I
could just YouTube it type a new story
or 3d home letter work and and it this
is this concludes phase one
for us which was make a 3d home printer
with our partner icon and print the
actual first house in Austin right which
we've done and now we shift into Phase
two which is we'll definitely have to
make product development on the printer
will make improvements more testing but
then bringing it down to El Salvador is
a place that we're gonna bring it to and
3d printing a community of homes is the
next phase that is happening this year
we hope to finish that you know q1 or q2
of 2019 the whole community it we're
extremely excited about it because you
know this type of technology if you look
back you know when there's a lot of
technological advances it usually does
not reach the families that need it most
first right there kind of one of the
last ones to get it of course um and
we're so excited because this could
change how we innovate shelter for the
family's need at most and I'm getting it
first which we have just a unique use
case of our homes are small right our
homes are simple and that's why we think
you could do it first yeah we want to
bring emerging technology to emerging
markets because that is the area those
are the areas where these technologies
aren't just to do things like that are
cool or to make us a bit more
comfortable
it's where emerging tech has the
opportunity to truly change lives and
communities and societies and countries
so you know we feel like this is kind of
one step what we're doing with
construction to like fast forward these
technologies to the places that need it
and in everything that we do we really
hope that we can help inspire this
sector right like if more organizations
for their respective problems in food
security and education wherever if they
are investing in R&D seeing what
technology might be applicable to their
specific use case and you know bringing
it to the places that they work I think
we can you know solve a lot of the
world's biggest problems a bit faster
partnership models interesting as well
yeah we got how did you guys write a
news story yeah how did you go about
doing that
well I think it depends on what's the
ambition of your organization right and
and we've chosen to say hey there's this
huge problem right of about a billion
people that lack shelter we want to try
to make the biggest dent in that
possible right and then so that's the
thing big and the reverse engineer and
you think okay you can't do that as one
organization raising money right you're
governed by what you could do but then
you look at the market and you see there
are thousands of nonprofits almost every
government has budget or is working on
this issue but what we think that is
missing is more Rd and more innovation
right so we want to prove it ourselves
and then say let's get to scale by
democratizing this and like sharing with
everybody and then getting adoption from
all of those partners I don't do it I
think you you hit that and tears I think
you're asking about icon the icon
partnership so I think this is a good
lesson and Bret does this so well you
know for people who are thinking about
starting a business or they've started
one to just talk to people talk to as
many people especially you know
qualified people as possible about your
idea cuz you never know like where the
dots may connect so when we were doing a
lot of research and we said you know 3d
printing is very interesting at that
point we did not know very much beyond
what we had like read and seen and Brett
really just started talking to everyone
about it and we're you know very you
know grateful through IC through other
you know programs to have an incredible
network so we you know you really talked
to just everyone you knew what do you
know about 3d printing you know anyone
in the space have what have you learned
like what can you tell us and because
through that and someone was like oh I
actually know these guys in Austin Texas
who are experimenting with this and you
know the more you talk about your idea
the more you ask questions the more you
look to gain knowledge I think the more
opportunities present themselves to you
so we got connected to these folks in
Austin the icon team Jason Alex yeah who
are they absolutely incredible shout out
to that
and they obviously have they had it
built the this printer as we know it yet
but they you know through some
prototyping we knew that they had the
technical chops but then also there was
a shared set of values right so icon is
a for-profit company they'll be aiming
to build homes here in the United States
through 3d printing and other methods
which is really exciting but they had
shared values they really care about
affordable housing in the United States
and they saw this opportunity to partner
with us again to take really promising
technology for construction to places
where we can immediately apply it you
know we're not I think there's a lot of
if you look at even new stories video
all right if you look at news stories
three no shadows what I'm saying if you
look at the video the suggested videos
after it will be other videos of you
know homes that have been 3d printed in
the last you know one to three years so
you know this is not necessarily the
first 3d printer period but what's
significant about what we've done is a
it's not experimental we're not doing it
just to see what's possible right a lot
of the printers that exist are more so
in an R&D phase because they're targeted
towards a for-profit or luxury market or
even like building in space right like
we are we want to bring this down to
earth and say we have issues of housing
here now and so you know we were really
bullish on you know let's get this out
of the like experimental you know frame
of mine and it let's make it actionable
it's like print homes that people are
going to be living in in the next year
and so so they very much agreed with us
they believe that you know that the
technology is ready today so the
partnership is made a ton of sense so
for other nonprofits how does it work on
the financial side like do you guys
license it do you buy the 3d printer
from them how do you set it up it's a
nearly days and to be honest we have we
have to first prove it ourselves and
like doing an Austin is one thing do
printing a community of homes in El
Salvador is the next goal yeah and so we
have to
with ourselves and then we'll talk
through and figure out what's the best
model to scale that out which we don't
have clarity on exactly yet okay I think
something else that distinguishes the
printer that we've built it's all the
design constraints that we gave the icon
team right so a printer that's gonna
print a home you know in the US or many
of the examples you see in some places
in China they're not going to
necessarily work in Haiti and I'll solve
it with our specific design constraints
so it's hard enough to build a 3d
printer and on top of that we were like
hey engineers you have to make sure that
if power goes out midway through that
we're not gonna you know have an issue
that if potable water is not readily
accessible we're not gonna have an issue
manning the machine has to be easy
enough so that we don't need like super
highly technical talent in order to
operate or to fix the machine so our
printer that we've designed is a printer
that's ready to work in some of the most
remote areas in the world some of the
you know most difficult to work places
in the world which is the first of its
kind yeah and this has all happened in
less than a year like we had an i/o
we're at one you know a team we do these
fun quarterly summits every year we go
place and we actually have one night at
dinner we do moonshot ideas and
everybody has to just like pitch big
moonshot ideas and we've actually got a
lot of good stuff from that exercise and
3d home printing was one of the things
that came up that night and a year ago
yeah just so year ago just an idea and
then we started to explore it more
explore more and talk to the right
people and then say all right well we
this is we've done a lot of due
diligence like this was a calculated
risk and we got to the point where we
said okay new stores gonna invest this
amount of money and we're gonna do it
where if we lose it we're gonna be okay
right of course like this isn't a big
company kind of thing like actually not
at all no significant but not that and
then we said okay the worst case is we
lose it we're going to be all right we
learn we move on the best case is we
could innovate shelter for the families
that need it most and and when you look
at that and you analyze that we thought
it was irresponsible not to
right because if it works it could
change everything and it could reach
more families that need shelter faster
so that was kind of how we made our
decision yeah yeah what's the hardest
thing you see coming down the road like
doing it at larger scale what's gonna be
challenging everything there's a lot you
know I hads always like on the ground
because I kind of run our own ground
operations so one of the one of many
challenges will be just people wrapping
their minds around it on the ground I
think mmm talking to you a lot of people
who are listening when you first hear a
3d home printing me even you're just
like is it plastic how does that work I
don't get it
and so you know it would be naive of us
to assume that we're gonna print a
community of homes in you know a watch
up on they'll solve a door and then
people are gonna be super excited to
live in them without knowing hey is this
safe you know you're worried about your
children right if I look I would not
move me in my future hit into a home
that you know oh you ought to be like in
a science experiment exactly you don't
want to be a guinea pig to something new
and so while we know that it's you know
incredibly safe and durable etc there's
gonna be a lot of kind of just education
and talking to people and you know
getting their minds around it by they I
mean you know both the families that we
are working with it that we you know
build homes for as well as you know
governments and you know local
architects and you know people literally
operating the machinery - yeah that's
wild yeah yeah the whole the whole thing
is we have a kind of a much always say
as a team like it's for sure a seemingly
crazy idea right now especially when we
bring it down to El Salvador and like
show people and everything right -
governments - a lot of people listening
it's a crazy idea like until it's not
right until we can prove that it's not
and so we say like it's crazy until it's
not but we also know that this is
obviously not guaranteed right this is
an R&D project that we feel now actually
more confident than ever in because of
how the first phase went but we have a
long way to go
last August when we said we're gonna
start building this printer yeah we want
to do it by Southwest help us and was
helped by Southwest in March at that
point no printer existed right and not
only was the printer built but the house
was built and that's just to say like
you know it seemed very crazy it seemed
audacious but it happened
hmm and I think when you're like super
crystal clear on what your goals are
that's just incredibly powerful in order
to make it happen yeah so what
percentage of the team was working on
this because like obviously so I mean
you guys already spoke to it but all the
troubles that you're dealing with all
the challenges to making stuff like
shipping things everyone has the same
problem like how much of the team was
working on this and how did you get it
to move so quickly yeah in the beginning
it was really just Alexandria and I so
Alexandra's our CEO CEO and co founders
and we weren't spending that much time
like I think we pretty disciplined on
like five to ten percent like our weekly
time in the early days right and then
you learn more and it grows and then we
really only brought on one other person
from our team to help in Joanne and she
wasn't spending like that much time on
it either so we're able to do it where
we kind of carved out a percentage
basically like our weekly schedule yeah
that we were going to allocate towards
it and we just stayed pretty disciplined
on that because I think there's a there
has to be a balance of like obviously
you want to go out and have like
exciting new creativity and innovation
but you can't do that without the
discipline focus on everything else
totally and so in the beginning I think
what's really critical and one thing
we've done really well I already
mentioned this with local partners in
the countries that we work in
but finding people who are experts in
their space right while Brett and I did
a ton with research legal project
management launching etc we're not
mechanical engineers right we're not
cement experts yeah and so you know what
we did was find those people and then
help coordinate you know us all working
together to get toward a common goal
yeah well it's so easy to take your eye
off the ball right because I mean as by
nature she's a shiny object is
like the reality is it yes it is it's a
shiny object and we saw that in our
launch two weeks ago I mean we had been
like I think like six million views now
over 500 media outlets have written on
it and not not yet it was good and we
and we prepared heavily for that but
other donations looking within the last
week we now have about like 1.3 million
in donations so it's resonating with
people yeah
and burst we've were funding basically
more of the Rd of the printer okay of
the next product development phases yeah
you got to put yourself in the mindset
of like like obviously people can fund
houses which is incredible and an
amazing and life-changing and there's a
very small amount of people that
understand like creating a product like
this that if it works and then could be
scaled out around the world like that's
a massive impact and that's people are
starting to fund that as well yeah I
think about you know the government of
Mexico they're building tens for than
thousands about tens of thousands of
homes per year that would kind of fall
into that social housing bracket and so
if this technology is promising it's
able to slash costs you know be safer be
quicker etc imagine that you know the
governor of Mexico being able to use
this to make their work more efficient
and the savings right that may go into
other social programs that may help to
alleviate poverty in different ways
mm-hmm
you guys have been so effective at like
picking a goal and going for it both on
the fundraising side and on the product
side what other advice you have for
nonprofits that are going through YC or
just watching this and just curious
about you in terms of like the
fundraising which I know it can be
really challenging for nonprofits and
then like you know just having the guts
to like go for a product which is again
like like you said your investors are
excited about these goals that you have
but not everyone is like that's a whole
sales process as well like how do you
get to be in that kind of position yeah
well big question before that was a long
cord you get I think it really like
people ask us a lot
of yeah you know how can how can other
organizations be especially nonprofit or
social impact organizations like how can
you be more innovative or how can you
you know do some of these things and I
think just the reality is it all sorts
of people mm-hmm right you have to have
the right people on your team that have
the competence to innovate or to be an
engineer or to have the right networks
and so yeah we really value we really
like like I believe with all my heart
our number-one asset as an organization
is our team and our culture and then
that just it spirals to other areas of
like what kind of advisors can we
attract right and then we start getting
a few or sperry respected advisors or
board members and then they get to know
what's better and they're starting to
tell their team about it right and so
it's like kind of this domino effect
where you have at the tip of the spear
is definitely a clear story of like why
your organization matters and how
important it is for you to do what
you're trying to do for us it's a lot
about you know accountability direct
impact working with locals human
centered design innovation R&D and just
like tripling down on that story with
clarity and then getting the right
resources behind you that are excellent
as best as you can and then over time
that that builds yeah +12 everything
Brett said team absolutely critical we
actually take I mean people really
remark and kind of anxiously laughs
after they go through our hiring process
but it's actually but yeah it's like a
part-time job to go through it we take a
really long time I think especially as a
small team it's so important cuz it's
like family spend more time with these
people than anyone else in the world and
so you know we do interviews with like
every single one of our team members
they come into the office and they work
for a day like we take a long time to
like vet and bring people onto our team
so that when they come on we're fully
confident in their work ethic and their
sense of urgency and there you know
values character etc relationship
building you know that's something that
I'm actually like learning more of the
importance I think Brett's like a mask
of that and that's one of the reasons
why we have such an incredible group of
advisers donors people just advocating
for us because you know we treat them as
part of the new story family right
poor giving updates no you know when
they have a kid sending them a new story
ones it's just like relationship it's
really genuine right like these people
are investing in like our vision for how
the world should be and so you know we
want to invest in them and continue to
build those relationships as well so
just like genuine relationship building
is key and then for nonprofits I think
for for profits too but yeah at the end
of the day none of that matters if what
you're doing on the ground is not
actually working so it's really critical
to a get the right people on your team
to always be testing your hypotheses to
you know be super critical of your work
and to make sure that you are actually
having meaningful impact because if you
did none of the other things and you
just did that right you like make
something people want you do incredibly
impactful work then it might be slower
but you will eventually get other people
to like support and rally around you
whether gonna be team members whether
that be you know donors etc if you're
doing really high-impact work so that
cannot be overstated I'd say one one I
just thought this in my head like one
equation that I think we've done well
for fundraising and other growth and
other resources is I think first point
you have to have like credibility of
who's supporting you what is the work
that you've done order your results what
is your story right so you have to build
that up right which takes a lot of
tenacity and all the things you get it
started and then it's like how do you
get the attention of like influential
people and I think it's the equation of
first having the results and the
credibility and then being very creative
of how you're getting to those people
right right so we do like really weird
and creative things of like getting to
people right like we'll mail a Lego kit
of our house to somebody that we really
want to get in front of right we'll make
we don't sit just in emails we'll make
videos and we'll send like a video of us
like directly to somebody right like we
just try to think really creatively of
how
we get these people's attention because
if they could just give us 10 or 15
minutes of their time we know that our
story and our credibility and our
results will speak for themselves but
these people are extremely busy right
and having very important things to do
and they're not just gonna come find new
story yeah right you have to be very
creative of how you're getting people's
attention and the more humanized you can
make that and the more unique you can
make that the better hap it happens if
you do if you use like traditional
methods just expect kind of traditional
ordinary results yeah probably below
average oh yeah just like no one
especially these high-profile people
they're so hard to get in touch with I
mean you see it a demo day right like
yeah here you are full of these like
you're just surrounded by another
hundred great companies yeah and that's
like a refined piece of the world
already you have you have to UM use this
term always you have to take really big
swings of like and that means investing
a lot of time even resources into
something right so for example right now
we have this new program we're very
excited about it's called her story and
it's focused just on single mothers that
we work with in our communities and we
are going out and sharing this program
with like empowered female leaders in
the u.s. right and so we have kind of
our dream lists of people that we'd like
to get involved and then instead of just
like sending them an email or doing
whatever we actually made these and
Hannah Potter who runs his program we
made these like beautiful custom like
invitations like beautiful and like look
like a wedding random that they do look
like wedding it looked like like amazing
wedding invitations with like a custom
note on the back and like we're mailing
old foil we're mailing that like via
FedEx so that everybody opens FedEx up
like to either them or their chief of
staff or their assistant yeah and it's
like that's the kind of stuff where even
though that it's gonna be a small
percentage like we've invested so much
into making that happen there we will
get traction from it and we have and we
have yeah yeah and that's great advice
any closing words of wisdom for people
hmm Wow co-founder is out there I mean
our co-founder relationship I think
everything starts there and and before
you can build a great team you have to
have just excellent cohesion at the
co-founder level I feel one of the
luckiest things and the best day of my
life was being able to meet Matthew and
Alexandria and our other co-founder Mike
and the the chemistry that we have the
how we split up time how we check egos
at the door like there's no ego at news
story and how humbled together that
creates a culture right of what it's
expected to be when you join new story
and then that that impacts you higher
that impacts the companies that want to
work with you all the things so I think
it starts with there and it goes down to
here
yeah iron sharpens iron right that's
what your co-founder relationship and
other people who are you know starting
businesses or who who maybe aren't right
that's not the entire audience I think
just having an incredible community of
very supportive and bright people around
you so like I'm super lucky that I have
that every day when I go into work with
my co-founders and we had chatted about
this earlier but I also have a group of
other female founders through YC that
our community for me people who you know
are never resentful or jealous they're
just like complete cheerleaders for you
you know doing doing big things doing
things that haven't been done before
yeah it's really scary and challenging
and hard and in all of our careers
whether or not you're a founder you're
gonna have so many challenges and having
sounding boards and having cheerleaders
and just having a really great community
around you helps you feel empowered and
not lonely like the lone like a journey
like this can be very lonely so I think
like placing a lot of effort and
emphasis on creating really strong
communities of cheerleaders around you
one one last thing that we've we've
always said this for the last three
years but especially with a new 3d home
printing launch is that you know bold
ideas attract bold people mmm-hmm
right
and the more audacious the bigger the
idea is that's gonna attract more of
that caliber of person right they either
wants to fund it that wants to partner
with it or wants to come you know give
up their job at Google or Facebook and
come work with you right do it and so
you if your startup founder out there
you've you've got to have bold ideas if
you if you want to achieve you know you
know kind of spectacular results right
especially bold ideas that aren't just
PR stunts it's like this this is the
kind of thing like yeah it's sort of an
understanding of asymmetric risk right
like if this works out it's gonna be
amazing but the downside is like very
limited yeah but it seems like it's
working really well for you and I would
ii the the group meetings that's like
one of the things that people don't talk
about all that much in terms of YC
benefit yeah after the fact yeah just
keeping that up that's so smart yeah I
mean I I I'm like I feel lucky because
Ali will go have dinner drinks with with
her girls which are like amazing
founders and she'll come back with like
all these great idea is in like all this
new stuff on hiring and culture and like
everything and it's like wow it's
amazing yeah so just like minded people
around you are gonna like push you
toward your your goals right yeah if you
read the news all the time it's like
only awesome hi updates but that's not
the reality yes that's very true yeah
thank you
and then just one last this is not
advice but one thing that just always is
in my heart is you know YC Y Combinator
obviously you know has to return of
financial ROI
right like you know based on what the
company is but I think really at the the
core of the culture like what gets YC
partners excited what gets though IC
community excited is solving really big
problems right or kind of just like new
ideas and innovations to make the world
a better place and so you know YC was
one of the first to flick with a
for-profit lens look at nonprofits
nonprofits get a bad rap but essentially
these are all people that are trying to
solve the world biggest like most
intractable problem
and so you know I just have the utmost
respect for the YC community for you
know taking all the things that they've
learned about running good businesses
you know over I don't know how long it
is over time for decades or two years
now and helping you know apply and
create communities and create awareness
around the organizations that are really
working to try to make the world a more
equitable place
it was very nice and much respect yeah
well thank you so much for coming in
this has been great our pleasure thank
you thanks Greg
you